il y en aura forcément un près de chez
vous voici la nouvelle espèce de radars
tourelles qui devrait bientôt fleurir
sur les bords des routes de martinique
les tourelles c'est la toute dernière
génération de radar multifonctions ils
seront capables de contrôler jusqu'à 32
véhicules à la fois et à terme de
détecter de nombreuses infractions
franchissement de feux rouges
dépassement par la droite non port de la
ceinture ou du casque téléphone au
volant
une technologie redoutablement efficace
dans ce document de présentation que
nous nous sommes procuré la liste des
propositions d'implantation est longue
comme un jour d'embouteillage au total
105 emplacements seront retenus pour les
dispositifs de sanctions automatisés
mais attention ils ne seront pas tous
opérationnels en même temps 21 radars
seront déplacés dans les tourelles au
bon vouloir des autorités
la martinique a été désignée comme la
guadeloupe territoires pilotes par le
ministère de l'intérieur
mais ces dispositifs sont ils
véritablement adapté à la réalité locale
ce n'est pas forcément l'avis de tous
les usagers de la route comme frédéric
bounni qui s'était déjà fait remarquer
en réclamant préfet la suppression de
radars sur la rocade
la première question pourquoi cibler la
vitesse alors que des études sérieuses
en entrée que d'autres facteurs étaient
en tête des causes accidentogène
pourquoi ne pas lancer une vraie étude
ciblée par rapport à fuir nos
territoires
les troisièmes question pourquoi ne pas
investir et ça c'est très important je
pense dans des films pédagogiques un
petit peu à l'instar de ce cas ce qu'a
pu faire le département de la gironde
les autorités semblent orienter le gros
des moyens sur le contrôle de la vitesse
or en 2017 l'alcool où la drogue était
impliqué dans un accident mortel sur
deux autres sujets de préoccupation les
deux roues
les motards représentait 30 % des tués
l'année dernière alors qu'en martinique
moins de 1 % des déplacements se font à
moto pire deux tiers des motards tués ne
portait pas le casque et près des trois
quarts étaient sous l'emprise de la
drogue
malheureusement vous avez un fléau
depuis quelque temps il ya beaucoup de
gamins qui osent les moto sans casque
sans plaque donc je vois pas ce genre de
phénomène ce genre d'individu les adore
qui reda ok par adore ça pose pas de
problème pour eux maintenant les raids
ont tous servi aux gens ont l'habitude
de rouler correctement
on ignore encore le montant de la
facture de ces dispositifs
mais quoi qu'il en soit l'installation
des premiers radars en 2005 s'était
accompagnée d'une nette baisse des
accidents de la route
mais depuis une dizaine d'années on
assiste à une stagnation du nombre de
morts il s'agit donc pour les autorités
de susciter un choc de comportement des
conducteurs et une sensation de contrôle
constant le sujet fera vraisemblablement
l'objet d'une grande campagne de
communication en temps voulu il est vrai
que l'installation des premiers radars
avait pu susciter une certaine hostilité
de la part d'usagers